Speaker 1: So this you have to see in advance
of the big Christmas holiday this weekend,
the former president Donald Trump sat down
with former Arkansas Republican Governor Mike
Huckabee, also the dad of Trump's own former
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders, who
herself is now running as a Republican for
governor of Arkansas.
I don't think I've ever seen an interview
like this, and a huge part of the interview
is about a fake issue.
Then that issue is the so-called war on Christmas.
There's music playing in the background.
Mike Huckabee is really focused in on Christmas
and sort of makes Trump out to be like a hero,
I guess, for saving Christmas, for bringing
back Christmas.
See if you can.
I challenge you?
See if you can determine the number of lies
told here.
Let's just jump right into the first clip.
Speaker 4: America had gone through a long
period where people quit saying, Merry Christmas,
it's all happy holidays.
You deliberately change that and openly said,
Merry Christmas.
We're going to say it again.
Any part of my campaign, you the country had
started with this woke, I guess, a little
bit before that.
Yeah, and it was embarrassing for stores to
say, Merry Christmas, you see this big change.
They want your money, but they don't want
to say Merry Christmas and then use red and
then use whites and snow, but they wouldn't
say Christmas.
And when I started campaigning, this was in
twenty fifteen.
When I started campaigning, I said, You're
going to say, Merry Christmas again, and now
people are saying it.
Of course, they're not saying a lot of other
things like George Washington, Abraham Lincoln,
Thomas Jefferson, and you know, those names
are being obliterated because of craziness.
Speaker 1: So there was a long period where
no one said, Merry Christmas.
That's not true.
Trump said that part of his campaign was saying,
Merry Christmas.
Now that may be true, but how pathetic is
that if it's true, Trump saying it like it's
something to be proud of, but it's not.
It's a joke.
If you ran on, we're going to say Merry Christmas
again, which, by the way, we nobody ever stopped
saying Merry Christmas.
It was never embarrassing for stores to say
Merry Christmas.
There were some stores who chose the more
inclusive Happy Holidays, but like, who really
cares?
And then Trump says they also aren't saying
things like George Washington, Abraham Lincoln
and Thomas Jefferson, who isn't saying those
names.
And also, what do those names have to do with
this time of the year?
Like, we're rich.
This is sort of like uncharted territory in
lies about what is happening in society and
culture.
People aren't saying these names, and Huckabee
just nods along like this makes sense.
Let's continue into the next clip.
Speaker 4: But they are saying, Merry Christmas
again.
We got that.
That was a big part of what I was doing, and
I will say it all the time during that period
that we want them to say, Merry Christmas,
don't shop at stores that don't say Merry
Christmas, and I'll tell you, we brought it
back very quickly.
Speaker 1: You really did.
And I think a lot of people
Speaker 4: appreciated that it was a part
of the American culture.
It was a part of who we are.
It wasn't to exclude anybody.
It was just simply a celebration of what America
does at Christmas and America and the world.
But America loves Christmas.
And whether you're Muslim, whether you're
a Christian, whether you're Jewish, everyone
loves Christmas.
And they say, Merry Christmas until these
crazy people came along and they wanted to
stop it along with everything else.
So I was very proud of that.
Actually, remember, I used to say, we will
say Merry Christmas again in front of these
massive crowds of people.
Speaker 1: So Trump says it like it's an administrative
accomplishment.
We brought back saying, Merry Christmas, Christmas,
and he says, even Muslims.
I don't know why you pronounce it that way.
Muslims like Christmas as well, which is really
something else.
I still don't know who cares about this.
And every time I say this was not ever a real
issue.
A couple of people will email me and they'll
say, David, no.
There was a cultural backlash at one point
where the pollsters were saying, You shouldn't
say Merry Christmas or whatever.
Almost no one ever cared about this.
I'm Jewish.
I recognize most people are Christian by culturally.
Ethnically, I'm saying when someone says,
Merry Christmas to me, and it has happened
a lot in the last 10 days.
I don't get offended.
I just don't say it myself.
I'll either say thank you and walk away.
If someone says Happy holidays, I'll say likewise.
Happy holidays, have a good new year.
And sometimes if someone says, Merry Christmas
to me, I'll say, Oh, happy Hanukkah.
Like, if they're wishing me something about
what they celebrate, I'll wish them happiness
for what I celebrate.
Like, it's no big deal.
People will laugh.
It's just it just doesn't matter.
And Trump is calling this one of his major
accomplishments.
If you can imagine that now, it is true.
It doesn't really have any other accomplishments
to speak of, so maybe the fact that he says
Merry Christmas is like all he has to cling
to or something like that.
There's one more clip in this one.
Huckabee thanks Trump for not just saying
Merry Christmas, but for giving people good
Christmases.
And this is like, I mean, you know, this is
like North Korean propaganda.
Huckabee really should be blushing behind
that white beard that he is now sporting.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: President, I want to say because
of you, a lot of Americans have had some great
Christmases.
You helped rebuild the economy.
Pride in our country made us a strong military
once again stood up to China.
When I think of all the ways that you led
this country energy independent for the first
time in 75 years and no longer, I think a
lot of people are right now saying, I wish
Donald Trump was president right now this
year for Christmas.
What a great Christmas present that would
be.
Well, it's been very sad.
When you look, we were energy independent
and now they're going to OPEC again and and
they're begging for oil.
And the gasoline price was a dollar eighty
seven, and now it's in California seven dollars
and fifty cents a gallon, and it's going to
follow that.
And I said that during the debates.
I said, when you watch what they do to energy,
when you watch what they do with inflation,
inflation is a killer.
And so many other things, it's very sad to
see what's happening, but our country will
survive it.
And I really believe we're going to be greater
than ever before.
Speaker 1: A beautiful Christmas message about
begging OPEC for oil.
Still, Trump talking about 750 gas in California,
which, by the way, I was in California last
week, I looked everywhere for the $7 77 cent
gas.
Trump talked about.
Now I'm not saying it never existed.
Maybe there was some place in California where
super premium was 777.
I couldn't find it most expensive.
I saw with 649 let, by the way, I didn't put
that in my rental car.
I'm putting the cheap stuff in the rental
car.
I can tell you that for sure.
OK?
So a complete and total propaganda piece there
on Newsmax and everybody involved should be
completely embarrassed by it.